the minimalists want to help you avoid
impulse purchases that's why we created
five questions to ask before buying
which is now
a wallpaper for your smartphone now
you'll always have a reminder when
you're getting ready to purchase
something new
head on over to theminimalists.com
before
to download your free wallpaper today
hey josh i have a question before i ask
this how do i find life balance
now his question is how do i find
work-life balance what does that really
mean though when do people ask this
question
they are overworked they're overworking
themselves they're overextending
themselves and they
are in a position that they feel that is
unsustainable and i if they're asking
this question they're that's probably
what's happening or they're over life
or they're over life you're never over
you're never over life you're always
overworked right isn't that the thing
like
when people ask this question it never
comes from a place of like
you know i spend too much time with my
family i exercise
way too much and i
i spend an appropriate amount of time
eating healthy meals
the my big problem is i just don't work
enough
the person who's asking how do i find
work
life balance is saying how do i stop
working so much here's what i will say i
think by and large
balance encourages mediocrity
and if that's what you're seeking is
mediocrity there's nothing wrong with
that mediocrity is not
a bad word i'm mediocre in most of the
things i do
let me give you an example i cook my own
meals
almost every day and i do a very
mediocre job of it
there's no excellence in my chef
skills and i'm totally fine with it it's
not wrong it's not
bad it's not uh i shouldn't get
better like there's it's none of that
it is merely saying that i don't have a
deep desire to become a chef
and so work when we think about the term
work what we're talking about is that
well i have to show up and i feel like
i'm working too
many hours i never feel like i'm working
too many hours ryan because
i have a deep desire to do the
the work that we do yeah and in doing
that it's not like
oh i can't believe we have to record a
podcast today or i can't believe i have
to write this thing
it i don't need balance at all i simply
do the thing and so so yeah
even if you did feel that way we would
just be like okay then we're not going
to record as many podcasts
bingo it's yeah i mean there are uh
there are times when you've had health
problems where you're like hey
uh i'm not going to do interviews i'm
not going to do this can you do this for
me and i'm like yeah great i'll do that
for you and i don't feel overworked and
if i did i'd be like no
i can't do those things so i guess
they're not going to get done and that's
okay right and so
so really what you're saying there is
sometimes we say
no because we realize we don't have the
capacity to do a thing
just because you have the time to do a
thing doesn't mean you have the capacity
to do that thing tweet that podcast sean
and and
and so i think unfortunately mistake it
is like
well i can say yes to this or it's just
one more yes or
whatever it is but but we get
buried by our yeses
and and that's how we become obligated
and committed to a bunch of things we
don't want to be obligated to or
committed
to right and so how do i find work-life
balance
i found it by not looking for it anymore
the problem for me
was looking for work-life balance
there are 168 hours in a week and i'm
going to schedule them out methodically
and ordinally and
and i'm going to alphabetize my week and
by the end of it i was really stressed
out and miserable not sleeping enough
because i was fully balanced and so
yeah i reject your question